[Musica]
bene il 5 g temerlo o tenerlo la domanda
nasce spontanea dal momento che da
quando si è iniziato a parlare di 5g
sono iniziate le prime sperimentazioni
sul 5 g tutto quello che di male è
successo nel mondo ha visto appunto il 5
giri come indiziato numero uno
ora non so se qua c'è qualcuno che siano
5 g e quindi già mista odiando oppure se
c'è qualcuno che ha semplicemente dei
dubbi su questa nuova tecnologia
dubbi che nascono per le notizie che
vengono date
ad esempio il 5 g provoca la morte dei
volatili
nel luglio del 2019
ha cominciato a circolare una notizia
riguardante un evento accaduto nei paesi
bassi nel novembre del 2018
centinaia di uccelli cadono dal cielo
durante l'attivazione sperimentale della
legge 5 g quindi sono cominciate le
condivisioni di questa notizia tutti
allarmati tutti sdegnati da questa
tecnologia se non fosse che andando a
guardare nelle testate locali si
scoprirà che l'ultima sperimenta
sperimentazione in quella zona risaliva
al giugno e 2018 quindi cinque mesi
prima dell'accaduto durante la quale
nessun volatile cazzato maltrattato
anche in italia non ci siamo fatti
mancare le notizie del genere come ad
esempio l'immagine che vediamo con uno
stormo di uccelli morti a tech accaduto
a roma
tutti hanno cominciato anche qua a
parlare del 5 g ma la notizia il real è
un'altra cioè un pino per il forte vento
era caduto ha tirato giù un filo
dell'alta tensione e gli uccelli sono
morti folgorati
quindi si sa in questi casi anche a
genova sia in altre situazioni sono
dovute intervenire ha detto dei
rappresentanti delle associazioni
animaliste per chi arriva il fatto che
tra il 5 g e questi eventi non vi era
alcun legame
il 5 già provocato il covip equa
l'allarmismo appena iniziato a
diffondersi questa notizia è stata stato
eclatante tra l'altro si vede male ma un
conto e poli marzo del 2020 quindi in
piena pandemia su twitter ha scritto che
la scienza ha necessita di dimostrare
spiegare causa ed effetto
tuttavia garantendo osservazione dei
fenomeni correlati tra loro quindi lui
applicando quella che pensava fosse la
logica della scienza diceva quella è la
prima città al mondo coperta dal 5 gb
one qual è la prima regione europea
coperta dal 5 g
il nord italia
quindi sta facendo un
legame tra il 5 g la diffusione del
comite io vi chiedo solo di rispondere a
questa domanda se il 5 g causa la
diffusione del copit come mai il covip
si è diffusa anche in zone dove il 5 g
non è presente
altra notizia il 5 g facili dallo
spionaggio allora per certi versi questa
cosa può risultar era semplicemente
perché il 5 g offre una
una possibile superficie d'attacco
superiore rispetto a quelle che sono le
tecnologie
attuali perché il 5 g non tratta più
sulla una parte mobile per l'area di
telecomunicazioni ma tratta anche la
parte fissa
di contro cosa dobbiamo dire che in
molta applicazione molti scenari del 5 g
parliamo di latenze sulla rete quindi il
tempo che il dato rimane effettivamente
sulla rete internet
nell'ordine dei millisecondi questo cosa
vuol dire che anche utilizzando tecniche
di hadji computing cosa vuol dire
attualmente i nostri dati se devono
essere elaborati vanno verso server
tre modi che nemmeno noi sappiamo dove
sono e vengono elaborati quindi stanno
parecchio tempo sulla rete con il 5 g
si può si spostano questi server vicino
all'utente vicino a dove i dati vengono
prodotti quindi il dato rimane meno
tempo sulla rete subisce meno
esposizione agli attacchi e quindi
stiamo garantendo maggiore sicurezza del
dato il 5 g ed è una tecnologia nuova ma
le frequenze che utilizza non sono nuove
sono delle frequenze che già ci sono e
attualmente sono utilizzate in altri
settori
ad esempio vi siete mai lamentati del
digitale terrestre penso di no anche se
non vi prendeva qualche canale ma penso
di no eppure il digitale terrestre ha
utilizzato la frequenza dei 700 metri
fino a poco tempo fa infatti che è stata
lasciata libera all'applicazione del 5 g
anche le frequenze dei 26 gigahertz
quelle delle famose onde millimetriche
che portano all'installazione di
miriade di antenne piccole nella intorno
a noi
attualmente sono utilizzate per
comunicazioni satellitari
è con questa tecnologia
in pratica si vanno a
utilizzarli 20 6 gb s per le onde
millimetriche e quindi per realizzare
comunicazioni a corto raggio e a
bassissima potenza
inoltre l'agenzia internazionale per la
ricerca sul cancro ha classificato i
campi elettromagnetici a radiofrequenza
come cancerogene di tipo 2 b cosa vuol
dire sono possibilmente cancerogeni per
l'essere umano o questo possibilmente
nasce solo dal fatto che natura non c'è
niente che sia al 100 per cento non
pericoloso per l'uomo
dipende anche da l'utilizzo che se ne fa
ad esempio alla stessa categoria
appartengono le basse frequenze dei
dispositivi che abbiamo a casa quindi
quelli non fanno mai proprio il 5 g ci
lamentiamo
inoltre anche la l'uso di alcol e di
carne è stato classificato come
cancerogeno di livello superiore
come vi dicevo tutto dipende da quello
che è l'utilizzo che si fa di questa
della tecnologia è stato degli studi
hanno dimostrato che esiste una soglia
di esposizione oltre la quale è
verificato che c'è un effetto proprio
per questo motivo la commissione
internazionale per la protezione dalle
radiazioni non ionizzanti a posto una
soglia che 50 volte inferiore a queste
soglie trovata in italia addirittura
siamo a 5 mila volte in sotto questa
soglia cosa vuol dire vuol dire che
mentre i nostri vicini europei
hanno imposto una soglia di esposizione
di emissioni di radiazioni sui 60 61
volte per metro in italia siamo
addirittura 6 volt per metro è stato
anche chiesto di aumentare dagli
operatori
questa soglia ma non è stato ammesso la
cosa quindi siamo abbastanza protetti
inoltre le antenne 5g funziona in
maniera del tutto diverse rispetto a
quelle che sono le antenne classiche
finora mentre le classiche antenne come
quelle 4g italiano in tutte le direzioni
un po come succede se accendiamo una
lampadina a far luce in tutte le
direzioni con le antenne 5g attraverso
l'utilizzo di una tecnica chiamata
beamforming è possibile direzionare il
fascio di emissione solo dove si trova
l'utente e quindi evitare che sento non
c'è nient'altro non c'è nessun
dispositivo che ha bisogno dell'accesso
alla rete di oman di radiazioni
altre domande che vi chiedo perché le
antenne 5g fanno male ci lamentiamo ma
nessuno si lamenta o si preoccupa delle
antenne degli smartphone noi abbiamo
sempre i telefoni con noi attaccate al
nostro corpo qualcuno non usando
auricolari stacco il telefono fi
chiamate infinite ma il telefono ha
un'antenna un'antenna che comunque
trasmette e riceve
ovviamente segnale soprattutto ha una
potenza che varia a seconda della
copertura che c'è in quella zona
ultima notizia è quella che il 5 gt
fatto non migliorerebbe le prestazioni
della rete ora nel 5 gb viene introdotto
il concetto di orchestratore ovvero una
entità
centralizzata che riceve continuamente
dati dalla rete quindi monitora
costantemente la rete
ha una visione quindi globale e
applicando anche tecniche di
intelligenza artificiale fa sì che si
possa prevenire e risolvere in
[Musica]
tempestivamente eventuali problemi che
ci sono all'interno della rete inoltre è
possibile anche spostare quello che il
flusso dei dati degli utenti da una
pozione di rete che sta presentando dei
problemi adesso un'altra porzione che in
quel momento sta funzionando
magnificamente e quindi non
causa problemi all'utenza infatti
l'utente sarà all'oscuro di questi
problemi che ci sono a livello di rete
perché lui percepirà un servizio
continuamente ottimale
quali sono stati gli effetti di tutte
queste sheikh news che sono state fatte
sul sul 5 g ora che in italia molti
comuni hanno deciso di bloccare
l'installazione delle reti 5 g
con delibera comunale e ora con una
norma presente nel cosiddetto decreto
semplificazioni pare che questa cosa dal
governo sia stata bloccata e quindi i
sindaci non possono più posti
fuori dai confini italiani e la cosa non
è andata molto bene ad esempio in gran
bretagna hanno ben pensato una notte in
diverse zone di vandalizzare una ventina
di antenne 5g dandogli fuoco
quello che quindi dobbiamo capire che
siamo 7,8 miliardi di persone che hanno
bisogno di una rete di telecomunicazioni
che sia in grado di soddisfare il più
possibile quelli che sono i servizi che
noi stessi chiediamo lo abbiamo già
visto durante il lock down quando grazie
alle reti di telecomunicazioni in
pratica siamo rimasti connessi
nonostante fossimo tutti a casa il 5 g
ha l'obiettivo di portare ancora più
possibilità agli utenti e quindi non
deve essere visto come il male come il
nemico dell'essere umano ma come un
qualcosa che ti aiuta
come ti aiuta attraverso una rivoluzione
che viene fatta nell'architettura stessa
della rete in modo tale da offrire nuovi
servizi è più come connessione con più
comunicazione
come il 5 gb migliorare quindi la nostra
vita
nell'ambito medico sono stati già fatti
degli dei trials ad esempio a milano già
nel 2018 è stata presentata la prima
ambulanza connessa in 5 g cosa vuol dire
che in questa ambulanza via è installata
una telecamera in 4k il soccorritore
grado dato di episodi o lorenza realtà
aumentata e poteva effettuare una
chiamata una connessione con l'operatore
che sto in ospedale e iniziale non solo
a inviare tutta una serie di dati utili
per la diagnosi del
dell'assistita in quel momento ma anche
iniziare a fare tutta una serie di
pratiche che non ma l'operatore senza il
supporto di un medico magari non può
fare
sempre a milano all'ospedale san
raffaele è stato effettuato il primo
trial clinico di chirurgia da remoto con
la riparazione di una valvola mitrale da
remoto e con tecnologia 5 g cosa abbiamo
fatto noi
all'università
abbiamo ideato quella che potrebbe
essere una body area network ovvero la
possibilità di installare dei
trasmettitori anche sottocutanei che
continuamente monitorando lo stato di
alcuni parametri vitali mandano queste
informazioni comunicando tra di loro
attraverso connessioni ultrasoniche a un
un dispositivo che potrebbe essere lo
smartwatch che abbiamo da questo
smartwatch vanno verso un cellulare dove
giro un applicativo che prende questi
dati li manda sulla rete e arrivano
all'operatore l'operatore terremoto
quindi in ospedale o in uno studio
privato può analizzare questi dati ed
eventualmente prenderà anche interventi
immediati
l'applicazione del 5 g invece nelle
città fa sì che le città diventino smart
cosa vuol dire trasporti pubblici e
privati intelligenti immaginiamo i
veicoli a guida autonoma questi veicoli
sono dotati di telecamere sono dotate di
sensori che fanno sì che il veicolo
possa avere visione di tutto quello che
è l'ambiente intorno a sé e quindi
essere in grado di poter percepire
pericoli o altro e guidarsi da solo
nel nell'ambiente che centrano il
veicolo ovviamente cosa facciamo andiamo
a installare anche la dei sensori senza
gli utili che possono misurare varie
cose ad esempio è una fuga di gas
ad esempio è un problema nella cat e
idrica lo stato dell'aria l'inquinamento
dell'aria e così via
e tramite degli attuatori prendere delle
decisioni
quindi se io sto vedendo che c'è una
perdita sulla rete idrica
magari o un attuatori che mi blocca il
passaggio dell'acqua in un punto
precedente evito di perdere ancora
poi è possibile anche andare a
installare delle piattaforme di
trasmissione di video trasmissione che
fanno sì che possano essere offerte
ancora più servizi agli utenti
immaginiamo servizi di videosorveglianza
servizi di guida assistita e quant'altro
anche ad esempio la banale gestione del
traffico attraverso la gestione
intelligente dei tematiche quindi io
monitorando lo stato del traffico decido
come far funzionare i semafori rispetto
a come funziona un ora
attualmente
su questo cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo realizzato una piattaforma di
maurice di videosorveglianza distribuita
questa piattaforma permette agli utenti
di collegarsi e ricevere il flusso
proveniente da telecamere che sono
installate in varie parti della della
città ma non solo dopo ovviamente una
fase di registrazione per termini di
privacy e alto su questa piattaforma che
questa piattaforma non lavora solo con i
dispositivi con gli utenti finali ma
lavora anche con applicazioni superiori
le applicazioni in particolare sono
state realizzate nel contesto di due
progetti europei in collaborazione con
la onlus di ice e l'assetto pacati lab
entrambi del posto massimiliano salvi
che ha fatto un torca telex qualche anno
fa
la prima applicazione tourist ice questa
applicazione permette a persone non
vedenti turisti o normale persone non
vedenti che si trovano in una città a
loro sconosciuta di potersi spostare
tranquillamente all'interno della
crocetta in pratica se loro tramite un
applicativo indicano il punto in cui si
trovano si trova nel punto in cui
vogliono andare se questo percorso è
coperto da telecamere avviene il
riconoscimento della persona dall'alto è
il non vedente viene guidato tramite dei
degli impulsi sonori che riceve sugli
auricolari tipo dei vip come i sensori
di parcheggio in questo modo io riesco a
guidare la persona non vedente in totale
sicurezza su una linea immaginaria che
per esempio collega quei due punti
un altro applicativo invece light person
recognition cosa fa supponiamo di avere
una persona anziana a casa un calo che
video da solo sta andando questa una
telecamera a casa sua io sono in grado
di tramite il flusso che poi andrà
quella telecamera identificare se quella
persona si accascia all'improvviso terra
per un malore o per qualunque motivo
e quindi nel momento in cui io vedo che
quella persona rimane ferma posso posso
mandare un alert non solo ai suoi
parenti ma anche ai soccorritori in modo
da poter
intervenire il prima possibile
infine come il 5 g può aiutare
l'industria
portando a quella che è la quarta
rivoluzione industriale l'industria 4.0
caratterizzata da innovazione
automatizzazione e miglioramento nella
gestione di produzione i macchinari sono
sempre connessi tra di loro sono
connessi e mandano continuamente dati a
un operatore remoto mandandoli in
formazione appunto su cose in tempo
reale sullo stato di produzione di un
pezzo sull'usura del macchinario o su
possibili guasti e ritardi che ci sono
nella catena di montaggio in questo modo
riusciamo anche a evitare che l'umano
debba compiere una persona debba
compiere lavori usuranti e in alcuni
casi anche pericolosi a seconda del
macchinario che sta utilizzando
voglio chiudere questa presentazione con
questa immagine
la storia si ripete nel 1889 nella
copertina di questa rivista
l'elettricità veniva presentata come il
demone incontrollato
immaginate cosa sarebbe successo se nel
1889 il mondo avesse deciso di bloccare
l'utilizzo dell'energia elettrica nelle
nostre case
grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]